calor mucho calor en españa' con la ola
de calor a más temprana del país en 40
años y la peor en al menos 20 los
ciudadanos buscan un lugar en el que
refugiarse pues mirad de esa clima tal
porque si este caso hubiese sido más de
ella no hubiésemos que el cambio sea tan
brusco nos hemos acostumbrado ya y bueno
más o menos es lo que tenemos aquí del
verano hasta noviembre con las
temperaturas de hasta 43 grados celsius
en el sur y también intensas en el
interior del país este fenómeno se debe
a una nube de aire caliente proveniente
del norte de áfrica y es peligroso para
la salud de la población puede provocar
desde desmayos náuseas y trastornos
cardíacos hasta convulsiones unas
condiciones con las que trabajar se
vuelve una tarea muy difícil no sabemos
cómo vamos a hacer
aquí
y eso es que hay de momento
aguantamos pero creo
y es que cada vez hay más olas de calor
en el sur de europa un fenómeno natural
que aunque no está directamente
relacionado con la crisis climática y el
calentamiento global sino es su carácter
extremo y prematuro según los expertos
un aumento de la media se traduce
precisamente en eso en una mayor
probabilidad de alcanzar valores
extremos por lo tanto es a esa mayor
probabilidad se traduce en que realmente
hay más horas de calor se prevé que esta
ola de calor persista en españa al menos
hasta el 19 de junio unos días antes del
inicio del verano el 21 de junio